ces images captées par un drone montre
l'ampleur du phénomène sur plusieurs
kilomètres des véhicules stationnés à la
frontière géorgienne avec alors bord des
citoyens russes déterminés à furent leur
pays en guerre chaque jour il serait en
moyenne 10 000 à se présenter au poste
frontières de verk millars des arrivées
qui ont doublé depuis la mobilisation
décrétée par Vladimir Poutine mercredi
dernier quelques jours plus tard le
Kremlin a durcit les peines encourus par
les déserteurs et arrêter au moins 1200
personnes opposées à la mobilisation
alors dans les embouteillages le climat
est devenu très tendu
[Musique]
des citoyens russes et leurs familles
qui refusent d'être déployés en Ukraine
300 000 réserves ont été appelés en
renfort
un match politique notre président après
avoir déclaré la guerre à un état voisin
tente maintenant d'entraîner la
population dans cette guerre fratricide
ne fait que tuer il a tué beaucoup de
gens
dans les pays frontaliers de la Russie
les mêmes embouteillages comme ici au
Kazakhstan selon les autorités quelques
cent mille rues seraient arrivés dans
cet ex république soviétique depuis le
21 septembre l'agence contexte affirme
que 66 000 russes sont entrés dans
l'Union européenne depuis une semaine
Moscou estime qu'il est exagéré de
parler d'exode pourtant les images et
les témoignages de citoyens fuant la
Russie se multiplient à l'image de ce
couple en vacances au Monténégro ils ont
finalement choisi de rester
il n'y a pour moi aucun sens à revenir
en Russie je veux vivre je ne veux pas
aller en guerre ce n'est pas notre
guerre nous ne protégeons pas notre
patrie ce qui reçoivent une convocation
mais refuse de se présenter à un
commissariat militaire peuvent
théoriquement être considérés comme des
déserteurs